le violon s'entremêlent au maloya dans
le nouvel album de christine salem le
septième de l'icône réunionnaise
[Musique]
roche compose en fait j'entends la
musique et à chaque pas quand je compose
et les
une chanson j'entendais le violon et du
coup j'ai fait appel j'ai cherché un
violoniste si je suis tombé sur frais de
noël qui a rejoint le groupe pour cet
album là
[Musique]
cet album nous emporte dans des envolées
de louvres up maloya est la plaie merci
et merci à mes ancêtres parce que moi je
suis toujours dans la tradition
on or les ancêtres ont fait des
cérémonies
et aussi à toutes les personnes autour
de moi qui m'ont courage et
jusqu'aujourd'hui dans la musique
même les gens qui ont travaillé avec moi
c'est pour moi c'est une sorte de
reconnaissance
c'est dans un studio de radio france que
nous avons rencontré christine salem à
l'occasion d'une rencontre musicale avec
la batteuse anne paceo une session
unique
deux titres qui seront gravés sur vinyle
un partage comme les aime la
réunionnaise
[Musique]
franchement ça fait plaisir surtout de
travailler avec anne paceo les
rencontres ne nous adorent ça ne voit
que les fans musiciens s'intéresse aussi
à musique de la réunion donc s'élancer
en dernière
et du coup c'est super quand est-ce
qu'on soit une femme musicalement on a
une super entente même humainement et
c'est l'essentiel dans la musique en
tout cas christine salem reprendra
bientôt le chemin des concerts elle qui
n'aime pas la routine
son nouvel album est à l'image de son
état d'esprit spirituel sincère et libre
[Musique]